hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the pleasure of sitting
today with Creon Levitt who for three
decades plus was a NASA scientist he is
now still functioning as a scientist but
in a private capacity he is at a company
called Planet Labs uh that was founded
by some folks from NASA Creon welcome to
the Dark Horse podcast
such a pleasure Brett we've been having
private conversations and social
interactions for a couple years now but
it's nice to be uh I guess this is his
closest face to face as we're going to
get for a little while but lovely yep
so I should probably explain uh since I
think you are not widely known this
podcast was born of the idea that each
time we interacted we found fascinating
things to discuss and the Dark Horse
podcast is certainly about conversations
with people you might not ordinarily
encounter who have lots of important
things to convey so anyway you're uh a
perfect example of a Dark Horse who I
think people will be fascinated to hear
but before we get into the heart of the
matter I have to ask you as a
32-year NASA scientist how do you feel
about it when people say it's not rocket
science
oh that's a complicated topic but let's
just say that
um arguably rocket science is not so
hard rocket engineering is pretty hard
um
and um and because like 10 000 things
have to go right in order for a rocket
to successfully uh deliver its payload
to orbit and if any one of them doesn't
go right chances are it's not going to
work so it's a it's a really daunting
engineering task but and when people say
it's not rocket science I guess I get
some solace in that because I worked on
someone stuff like that
um go boost
yeah I I uh I agree with you about the
distinction between the rocket science
which is pretty straightforward once you
get it and the rocket engineering which
is never straightforward because of the
number of unknowns and uncontrollables
that interface with any given rocket by
the way can I drill down on that for a
moment because there's a very
interesting thing about Rockets
particularly about rockets that launch
from the earth which a lot of people
don't know you might ask yourself for
instance why is it that like 60 years
after we started launching Rockets they
still blow up and they still fail like
what other technology has this um
characteristic and the thing about
rockets launched from the earth is that
it is at the absolute limit of molecular
physics to be able to reach orbit from
the earth what I mean by that is that
you have to take the highest energy
chemical reactions that are available
from the periodic table basically like
liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen like
you know or or kerosene and liquid
oxygen like there's almost nothing that
combines with more megajoules per
kilogram than that you have to take the
highest energy chemical reactions known
to man you have to shove like you know
thousands of gallons a second into a
chamber that can hold this extreme heat
I mean basically it's what we would call
an explosion under any other terms but
it's it's a we call it burning or firing
or whatever and then this chamber has to
be made out of the highest melting point
materials and it has to be cooled and
all this kind of stuff and the reason is
because it's containing these extremely
high energy chemical reactions and the
point is is that with all that and with
these giant Rockets you get a payload
fraction to Earth orbit of just a few
percent of the mass of the rocket and
it's interesting that if the Earth was
any uh more massive you know with uh
deeper gravity well if you will
they wouldn't you couldn't bring a
payload to orbit the payload fraction
would be zero and so because of these
because of the situation
using these extremely energetic chemical
reactions the most energetic known and
using these materials and you have to
lightweight everything so that you get
you know you can apply that mask to the
payload fraction
you're running with razor thin margins
basically so unlike when you build a
building and you just like make the
beams twice as big as they have to be
because you got you want margin with
rockets if you made everything twice as
thick and strong as you needed it to be
no payload
so everything is Razor thin margins and
and and everything is right at the edge
and the technology hasn't really changed
very much in 60 years I mean we have
computers and stuff now but it's
basically turbo pumps and liquid Fuel
and the same chemicals and so this is
this is kind of why they still blow up
well that's fascinating I was gonna say
before you launched into that that I
find an important analogy between the
kind of thinking one has to do to
understand biology well it is not
similar to chemistry or physics it is
similar to engineering and economics
uh for various reasons one because
there's an objective but two because of
the balancing of compromising
of uh competing goals and so anyway it's
not surprising to me what you've just
described
is not terribly dissimilar to the
argument I deployed in my dissertation
about at least part of the explanation
for why species accumulate in the
tropics at a much higher rate than they
do in the temperate zone and the part
that's analogous to what you were
describing is that species in the
temperate zone it's impossible to have
two species that are equally capable
given the same environment you would
have one that had a slight Competitive
Edge inevitably
and the Tropics this isn't true because
they bump up on the same physical limits
to what is possible and the point is
those physical limits cause them to
converge so that they have exactly the
same competitive capacity and nobody
displaces anybody else they actually
drift in competition against each other
they are competing ferociously but you
can't get an edge and so what you're
saying about Rockets is we figured out
how to do this at the limits long ago
it's not so different we can now
calculate more effectively with a
computer but it's the same limit that
we're reaching it's a physical limit
you told me something I didn't know
which is that if the planet were denser
or bigger
um that it would make the launching of
rockets that had a positive payload
impossible well that's the same
exponentially worse like like it's like
the payload fraction is already down to
a few percent with the earth and the
payload fraction kind of gets
exponentially worse as the gravity
increases and this is on the other hand
why from they could launch back from the
Moon with this like little tiny thing
that had almost no power at all you know
and used very simple
because the moon's gravity is so much
less it's relatively quite easy to
escape
and uh because the moon doesn't have an
the thing people don't Intuit about
something like air you intuited if
you're a cyclist and you realize
that
know the difference between going uh 10
miles an hour and 15 miles per hour is
nothing like the difference between
going 15 miles per hour and 20 miles per
hour that the reluctance of the air to
get out of the way creates this obstacle
that grows ever more ferocious as you as
you the difference between your speed
and its standing still so presumably if
the Earth had bigger gravity then you'd
have a thicker atmosphere and then they
would just be doubly worse I mean yes
you're right atmospheric losses gravity
losses all kinds of losses accumulate
everything's right at the edge it's very
strange that it's like almost an
anthropic coincidence that you know
we're in a we're living on a planet
where not only is everything tuned for
life but it's like just below the
threshold of getting access to space
well but this also raises another
question so I just before we close out
that other topic so the other nice thing
as a biologist looking at something like
the moon landing
um getting off the Moon Not only do you
have low gravity and there's no
atmosphere that you have to push out of
the way but the lack of an atmosphere
means that any old shape will do which
takes away a lot of the constraints on
what the thing had to look like which is
why you got such an ugly duckling of a
Lander yes
um you know able to get back up to the
Orbiter this episode is sponsored by
Ranger Tugs
let's arranger tug I hear you ask
a ranger tug is a small boat that
punches way above its weight class
Ranger makes a number of different
models including a 23 foot and a 25 foot
version that can live on a trailer in
your driveway or in a large garage and
be pulled behind a pickup they make them
both an inboard Diesel and outboard
gasoline versions these are boats that
can sleep four adults comfortably allow
you to store the ingredients for and
cook a full meal on board they have
solar panels to keep the batteries
charged
these are boats that you can take into
deep water and use the sonar to look for
fish or you can pull them in close to
Shore and anchor them or pull up to a
Mooring Buoy or a dock and use them as
base camp for land-based Adventures they
have a roof rack it allows you to carry
things like paddle boards kayaks even
bicycles
these are excellent boats Heather and I
took a ranger 25 out to a local Island
that has a state park on it that is not
served by ferries or by roads we had a
great time we got to watch
otters playing on the shore we saw orcas
and at night we got to see a beautiful
display of bioluminescence in the water
really extraordinary stuff and the stars
from the back deck absolutely fantastic
now boats aren't cheap anybody who's
looked at boats knows that can you
afford one I don't know that's between
you your spouse a religious Authority
and your Banker but if you are looking
for a boat this really is the place to
look if you want your money to go a long
way so check out Ranger tugs at Ranger
tugs.com and tell them Dark Horse sent
you
you mentioned the anthropic principle
the anthropic principle essentially
being that although the parameters for
let's say life are very unlikely to
converge it's not surprising that a
living creature would discover they live
in a place with exactly the right
parameters because of course that's
where a living creature would come to
discover that property if it's you know
it's a very rare set of conditions and
those are the only conditions where life
will arise and that's where the question
will be generated so it it's a reason
not to take this as a falsification of
the organic nature of evolution
absolutely true and I Nick Foster wrote
a whole book on this called anthropic
bias which is related to this matter
Langdon so let me ask you this I have
not read bostrom's book so maybe this is
addressed there but so you point to this
second kind of anthropic principle where
it's not the conditions necessary for
life but it's the conditions necessary
for us to do something like rocketry the
Earth uh allows it in a way that then
allows us to leave the Earth and and do
things elsewhere but here's what I want
to know
where you started
you made an argument that suggested that
given a planet let's say twice the size
otherwise similar but twice the size
thicker atmosphere more gravity uh or
stronger gravity that rocketry of the
sort we know would effectively be
impossible is that fair
yeah from an engineering perspective yes
I mean theoretically if the Earth had if
we had twice the gravity then we might
be able to build a rocket that was like
a million times bigger that would get a
few kilograms to space but that's not
practical okay so here's what I want to
know and is there a size of planet that
just simply takes rocketry off the table
obviously a black hole in a mathematical
sense there may not be because if you
can build an infinitely large rocket
then you can eventually get to the
velocities you need but um in a
practical sense it's impossible now of
course we're talking chemical rocketry
there's also that's what I was that's
what I was going to ask you is can we
extrapolate from this
insight to the idea that we will not
find other creatures out there having
left their Planet above a certain size
we might find life on a planet of a
different magnitude but that there is a
limit to the size of the home planet of
any space-faring creature we would
encounter is that yeah I think we would
expect this severe drop off you know
what I mean like on your drop off as the
planets get bigger the space fairing
gets way exponentially less but you know
there's also the possibility of nuclear
propulsion and experiments have been
done with that and there's a lot more
energy available there but that brings
other problems of its own like the
weight of nuclear reactors and things
like this and then there's uh beamed
energy propulsion where you use lasers
or something or microwaves to send
energy to the
um craft and so about it and and all
this stuff was kind of figured out
actually by the founders of rocketry a
century ago they knew that these
possibilities were available
and what about something could you
could you deploy the power on Earth and
make a projectile that would get itself
to orbit interesting you should mention
that there's a couple of startups right
now which you're doing just that they're
building and scaling systems where
essentially the first stage of the
rocket is on the ground and it's either
a big centrifuge or a big gun and it
launches a hyper velocity projectile
which is a little rocketed in itself but
in a way you're taking that first
booster stage of the rocket and
replacing it with a fully reusable
system on the ground so these look quite
promising nothing of course has been
scaled up to the level where it could
reach orbit using this but but uh it's
it's looking reasonable
interesting all right well that's
fascinating and not somewhere I expected
us to spend time but uh I've I've
learned a lot
um where else should we
uh Focus
do you wanna there's lots of stuff that
we could talk about with respect to
covid there's stuff we could talk about
with respect to uh intellectual
curiosity and how it develops and what
sustains it and what threatens it where
do you think we should head
well
um whichever way we had do you mind if I
just say a certain thing about
my opinion of you
well that depends if your opinion of me
is a very low one then I'd rather you
didn't no no exactly it's a very high
one and you and Heather and Zach I
believe that the that the uh that the
discussions you've been having and the
routing around of the censorship
industrial complex that you've been
forced to engage in
will go down in history as some of the
most important
information
of our contemporary era I think that you
are engaged in what I like to call Holy
work a lot of people who I associate
with are like oh you know Brett
Weinstein like he's just
it's like the dad horse podcast it's
like and it's not you talk about more
but I actually think that this is super
important that we don't let it go and
most people are and you are not and so I
um I want to praise you for your bravery
your tenacity
your open-mindedness and just your work
you and the whole team
um thank you that means a tremendous
amount to me and I I really appreciate
it there are elements of what you say
that I agree with and let's take me out
of the equation I think it is vital that
we understand what happened during covid
and as I have said from the beginning it
wasn't about covid covid
revealed what was true of our system
having nothing to do with disease and it
revealed it across the board such that
if we could look at it and say how did
this happen and actually get to an
answer to that question we would know
what we had to do to fix it
so that's why I don't want to let it go
right well and I don't want you to let
it go but let me bring this around to a
very interesting convergence between
rockets and covet or sort of and that's
the following
um at NASA when you have a mission
failure
which does happen you know fortunately
not all that often but you know we had
the Apollo one fire in the Apollo 13
mishap and the Challenger explosion and
the Columbia disintegration and re-entry
and we've had a number of uncrewed
missions that have also failed the
Hubble Space Telescope
had a
issues when it was first deployed and
other things have not worked missions
have failed even if no humans were on
board when NASA has a mission failure
here's what they do
they convene a panel of experts who had
nothing to do with the project
they Empower that panel of experts to
have access to all documentation and all
Personnel who worked on the project and
they instruct the Personnel to be
completely honest and transparent
to the increase and these mishap
investigation boards or failure
investigation boards or accident
investigation boards they work
oftentimes for months or even a year and
you know what happens they almost always
figure out what went wrong and why it
went wrong and then they write up their
reports like the Challenger one with
Richard Feynman is quite famous they
write up their findings they don't just
it's not about blame it's about figuring
out what went wrong
documenting why it happened to and then
making recommendations to make sure it
never happens again
and so I always thought during covid
when things started to obviously get
weird and go off the rails and and you
know it was obviously huge mistakes were
had been made I was like why don't we
convene a failure investigation board or
or maybe several because there's so many
different aspects
why did we get this wrong why'd we get
that wrong what did we learn what do we
do and and I for a long time thought
this was the obvious answer and this is
what you know a competent government
agency would do but you know it it
didn't really happen
some individuals have tried to do it
um
RFK Jr comes to mind with his his book
letter to liberals but you know it's
just one man
um and now unfortunately I think
I'm not going to say it's too late but
maybe it's too late and too early at the
same time I think that the problem is
you can't find people who have nothing
to do with it to be on this committee
because everybody's polarized one way or
the other and their minds made up you
know no I don't think that's why
actually that may be a component
but I think when when you consider what
NASA is
[Music]
the chances that somebody has an
interest
in Mission failure
or very low right your enemies might but
the chances that they're gonna get into
NASA and they're going to cause Rockets
to blow up what otherwise succeed that
you know I'm not saying it will never
happen but that has not been the answer
to what has happened yet and what that
means is that although certainly you
know there have been embarrassing errors
we've uh had
Mission failures because of unit
conversion errors yeah Imperial versus
metric units
but
aside from covering your ass when you've
made an error or you've you know you've
you've made the call that the space
shuttle will launch in spite of
temperatures to which the O-rings aren't
tolerant has happened in the Challenger
disaster so there is a cover your ass
Instinct but there is not a
nobody sells out the public
to hijack a NASA mission for other
purposes and therefore the covering your
ass is of a normal human scale
yeah I don't want to bash on NASA but I
want to push back just a little bit I
basically agree with what you said and
and and uh I think you're right that
that's a possibly substantial uh
Divergence between covid Mission failure
and mass emission failure but it is but
look there is a certain amount of
capture even within NASA like there's
companies that you know are on the gravy
train and they want to keep building
these expensive systems so like it shows
up in less dramatic ways but like maybe
they're not interested in building more
efficient systems or you know you know
it's a standard kind of Defense
Contractor mentality it's SpaceX has
disrupted that to some extent but uh
it's there so but but it's a smaller
it's a less it's Insidious but far less
uh
deadly form of uh capture than we saw
arguably in the coven and in Food and
Health in general
well I also think
that the
there's a question of how Divergent the
incentives are
it used to be that one expected Pharma
for example to push its profitable drugs
and to drive out
previous drugs that had lost their
patent you expected a certain amount of
that
and you didn't necessarily expect them
to push a drug that would actually harm
patients you just thought there was some
sort of shell game about which
prescription you were going to get you
might get a drug that was 20 less
effective because it was under patent
but you weren't expecting a toxin
and I believe this is maybe I've just
woken up to it but I believe this has
gotten
this has changed over time and that now
you actually have an industry in the
case of Pharma where
you know what is demand called
with respect to Pharma products
ill health so you have an industry that
wants demand which means it wants ill
health and it has woken up to how to
create that demand and then fill it with
the supply of something that may or may
not be efficacious by
creating the impression that something
is efficacious
but put that aside in the NASA context
even if you've got a contractor who
wants you to put something that they
make on your rocket and it's less
efficient than some competing thing that
you might source that would be better
for the mission right it's still not
antagonistic to the mission
and so if it became antagonistic to the
mission then I think your argument about
why NASA failures are
uh frequently understood in their
aftermath
would fail it would break down but for
the moment as long as everybody has an
interest in figuring out what went wrong
so it doesn't happen next time you can
have a proper investigation and the
punch line to that is
in the case of covid you have people
with the power to succeed actively
obstructing our comprehension of what
just happened well okay let me ask you
something based on that I agree but I
want to know
I don't mean to turn the tables and like
interview you and so feel free to
redirect this isn't an interview I don't
do interviews this is a discussion so do
what do what you feel is right okay so
you know I'm a long time listener and in
fact a long time listener from before
coven and we're going to get to this
about certain interesting uh
uh polarizations that didn't did not
happen with coven but for the moment I
just want to ask you this you've said a
number of times it's an observation that
I uh I think you were the first in my uh
awareness to make which is it's not just
that you know we had incompetency
because you'd expect them to be right
half the time if they were just doing no
better than a coin flip on you know
whether we should mask or not or lock
down or not or you know Rush the
treatments or not but but they seem to
have made arguably
the wrong choice wrong in terms of uh
beneficial to the public every single
opportunity and what I'm wondering is
um
do you do you have any more thoughts on
that like how can that even be explained
I mean it can't be that all these
everybody involved in all this stuff is
like an absolutely evil person and we're
all great good people I mean Canon it's
got to be isn't there some kind of
coupled bad incentive
Malak situation which is making it go
this way what do you think
um I think there's a I have come to an
understanding at least a placeholder for
what could explain such a thing with
normal human failing sort of a banality
of evil level of understanding
and it works sort of like this
first thing to realize is that we have
misunderstood sociopathy
that those of us who are not sociopaths
need to realize that there are quadrants
over which we have that capability
the fact that if I spend five bucks on a
cup of coffee
and that that five bucks could
potentially rescue somebody from a
debilitating disease Halfway Around the
World I'll never know their name they
will never know that I've helped them
why do I buy the cup of coffee it's
still a human suffering
so why am I not struggling to figure out
how I could just forgo coffee for the
rest of my life and every day
I could save somebody from something
terrible that would be a I I think that
would be a moral imperative if I could
figure it out
somehow some feature of my wiring
presumably normal ancestral wiring
has this person that I might
theoretically help remote enough from me
that their suffering is something I
easily Miss I just I go
weeks without thinking of it right so I
would argue that that is the stuff
of which you know sociopathy may be a
person who can do only that they are
inherently indifferent to anyone
suffering at all moments but the point
the fact that we all have it
facultatively on board is all I need for
my explanation here
now imagine that you're a normal person
that you do care about other people but
you don't care about all other people
and certainly not equally and you're
capable of caring about other people not
at all in cases where there's nothing
you can do or it's sufficiently hard to
figure out what to do that it would
occupy you it would waste all your time
right you learn to become indifferent to
that suffering
so let's say everybody brings that to
work all the normal people bring that
thing to work and then you go to work in
a context
where decisions that you make are
definitely going to kill some people
right like for example
you're in Pharma
let's say that you're in Pharma for the
right reasons you want to figure out
what drugs can be deployed to reduce
suffering to
preserve life to do all the things that
a Pharma might aspire to right
and you realize oh
every drug that I'm going to deploy
is going to kill some people who would
otherwise have lived and so it's a net
calculation I'm going to kill some
people who should have lived in order to
save some other people who would have
died
yeah and so you just get comfortable
with that now imagine that you're
designing automobile Interiors
that doesn't really sound like a life or
death thing until you realize that of
course if you make a car that's
perfectly safe
nobody can afford it and nobody will buy
it and it won't pass the economy
standards right for fuel efficiency so
you're going to make compromises that
are going to result in some people whose
names you'll never know dying who didn't
have to you just get comfortable with
that so what I'm getting at is
there are all kinds of places where
people end up on what turns out to be a
slippery slope of indifference and what
they trade is hey I'm going to get my
paycheck and I'm going to in order to
get my paycheck I'm going to have to
tune out the suffering of other humans
that are going to suffer as a result of
decisions I will make
once you're on that slippery slope maybe
it requires a moral defect
but people can end up almost completely
indifferent to almost everyone's
suffering and I think what we saw in
covid is
people who made decisions of a kind that
were very normal I my paycheck my
reputation depends on me ignoring the
suffering of people who will suffer
Downstream of decisions that I will make
and that there's no limit to how much
suffering these folks were willing to
inflict
in order to play the game of Pharma and
get ahead and to us that sounds shocking
because we just tuned into it and we
don't realize how much the game of
Pharma is this every day it's about
getting favorable coverage in scientific
journals which shouldn't be giving you
favorable coverage they should be giving
honest coverage right you know I'm well
I understand what you're saying I agree
it's a possibility and it's certainly a
one of the forces at play to that can
help explain this stuff I mean obviously
people's moral weaknesses and blindness
to uh consequences and self-interest you
know of course it can all conspire to
make things rather awful I'm not sure
that that explains ever all of it but
I'm I want to mention something
interesting to you because I'm pretty
much in your camp on all things covid
um but uh uh
you know I also am involved in a lot of
molecular biology stuff it used to be
something I did semi professionally a
little bit and then that's where I
learned the Immunology that we've talked
about in the past and then I just stayed
uh involved in some
seminar groups that are studying
longevity and life extension mostly but
it of course spreads out into all kinds
of
Pharma and biotech stuff and it's funny
because on the one hand I'm right with
you that there was like
um you know inadequate testing and
inadequate objectivity and inadequate
comment periods and all the stuff for
these various coveted uh decisions that
resulted arguably in a great deal of
harm on the other hand when you hang out
with these communities of people who are
trying to actually make new Therapeutics
that solve really new problems what's
their big complaint you know the FDA
takes too long the FDA slows everything
down you know we need to have an agile
FDA and so it's an interesting thing
that like they're damned if they do and
damned if they don't you know well
that's the problem is everybody's damned
if they do and damned if they don't I
certainly found myself there a thousand
times during covid but if you think
about what happened with
statins yeah for example or with ssris
scientific explanation
became gospel because it Justified the
administration
the standard of care being changed to
embrace compounds that overwhelmingly it
will turn out harm to the people to whom
they were prescribed
yeah or at least didn't do what they
were supposed to do except making a lot
of people Rich who were selling them yes
I by the way and so I want to ask you
another thing and see so
I wrote down a list of names this was a
couple this is a couple years ago during
like the sort of real pivot point in
covid where the wheels started falling
off the narrative and everything and I
realized that there were a bunch of
people who I have been following for
years because of my interest in Health
and Longevity and I turned my health
around I used to be an obese person with
terrible biomarkers and now for my age
I'm quite optimal even for someone much
younger and I did that by uh doing my
own research which used to be okay
um and uh used to be called reading yes
that's a great that great routine
absolutely so like ASI Malhotra
uh the whole low carb Community
um uh even Stephen gundry who's an
interesting case Gordon Locke the
founder of glycomics
um Johnny and Otis uh you know I was
following I could read off a list of
dozen people but I had been following
all these people
before covet because they seem to have
information that was counter narrative
but basically really stood up to the
scrutiny
anti-statin anti-stenting
anti-angioplasty I think anti
um
anti-sugar of course
anti-carb Pro meat you know all this
stuff was starting to make sense to me
and I was transforming my own body and
the bodies of my friends using this
information and then covid came along
and wouldn't you know it but like
more than 90 percent of these people all
ended up on our team
on covid and so that to me was part of
the
uh
reason that I kind of became at least in
my friend group really on the outside
contrarian or covet because they were
all like marching
in line with the narrative but I was
like you know
these authorities are totally
untrustworthy I knew this before kovid
like they were untrustworthy about
statins they were untrustworthy about
sugar they were untrustworthy about fat
they were untrustworthy about uh cardiac
stents and now you expect me to all of a
sudden turn around and trust them on all
this other stuff it's like
I think I'm in a reserve judgment and do
my own research for a little while and
and it's funny because all these people
who were
good at uh
understanding the subtleties of Health
in the previous context seem to pretty
much you know we know there's a few
like there was other people who weren't
biologists and doctors you know you're
uh you know the bear could be everybody
from like Barry Weiss to you know
various physicist friends of mine and
like Melissa Chan you know various
people right and they also ended up kind
of on our team but since they didn't
start off in biology and medicine that
was just interesting to me but what was
interesting to me with like almost to a
man or and almost to a person everyone I
was following in biology and Medicine
ended up kind of in my contrarian camp
on covid how did you
how did that work out for you
well I'm
I don't know how to put it exactly but
I'm concerned
about the way people woke up
I'm all for people waking up
I am not as you know I've described
something I call the middle ground
scramble
true enough where
the the power structure that screwed
covet up so badly and then lost control
of the narrative so it can't cover its
own ass
cannot afford to empower people who saw
through it early and have been making
these points and that it worked so hard
to silence the last thing it wants to do
is to validate that perspective so that
those people get asked what are we
supposed to do next how do we avoid this
happening again so what it wants to do
is it wants to empower
people the public is not going to accept
the mainstream narrative that it was fed
all along because it knows that's
so it has to the the power
structure has to be scolded and it has
to be scolded in a way that the public
finds credible but the public is looking
for
a an explanation of how it got taken for
a ride why was it so credulous when
there was so much evidence that it was
being lied to so you've got this
Confluence of forces that's looking for
contrarians who will not upset the
natural order of things they will not go
uh after those who created this problem
in the first place and seek to reveal
their full level of culpability so
they'll sort of slap both sides they'll
say
we're trying
to say that again mistakes were made you
know yeah mistakes were made the power
structure certainly didn't perform well
there were lots of signals that should
have been paid attention to earlier
obviously it's very embarrassing that
behind the scenes there were lots of
folks at the top aware that a laboratory
leak was the most likely explanation and
they sought to cover it up and that's
all very shameful on the other hand
the uh the covid dissidents were
so clearly in love with the idea that
everything was wrong that they embraced
lots of wrong Concepts like Ivermectin
Works blah blah blah blah blah so
you'll get this scramble to become the
new authorities in the middle who will
do very well they will end up their
their careers will soar in exchange for
them be willing to create a new
narrative that scolds the people in
power just enough but leaves them
exactly where they are maybe picks a
scapegoat or two but nothing important
is going to change and we will be right
back here next time
so I'm afraid of that and so what that
means is we have to distinguish between
people who had an organic trajectory
where they actually did wake up and I
include myself in this you know I've
told the story a number of times but I
became aware it wasn't called covet yet
it was called novel coronavirus but I
became aware of it when Heather and I
came out of the Amazon after completing
our the first draft of our
book and because I had been a bat
biologist I read the story of how uh you
know this was a type of virus that
circulates in bats blah blah blah seems
to have jumped to people and I put out a
tweet that said yeah this adds up to me
I know the family of bats in question I
know that they carry these viruses so
superficially speaking this makes sense
and I got pushback immediately and it
took me and the pushback was so it's
just a coincidence that this happened
right on the doorstep of one of the bio
safety level 4 laboratory studying these
exact viruses and I thought
I didn't
I didn't know that it was on the
doorstep and I certainly wouldn't have
said that I felt it was likely to have
come from bats if I had known that I
would have dug deeper and so in exactly
one hour I began to turn around now I
also blew it on hydroxychloroquine I
believed the evidence that it did not
work and was dangerous it took me too
long to figure out that that was not
true I was early on Ivermectin but in
any case and I harassed you I harassed
you into the right mask position I like
to take partial credit yes you did
harass me into the right Mass position
initially I was on board in fact I was I
would say a Pioneer in the idea that we
should be masking as a useful precaution
and then it turned out that the evidence
just simply didn't support it and I
changed position so anyway all of that
is to say I had an organic
right an organic evolution of my
perspective
and some some places I wish I had been
faster there's obviously a degree to
which you can't whip saw back and forth
with every new data point but
some of the progression is not organic
and by that what I mean is it is what
the traffic will bear people say people
know more than they say they move at the
rate that they avoid reputational damage
rather than saying what needs to be said
when it needs to be said and so
I don't know I think well I I did a lot
of that you know I'm imply I I'm in I
was employed by a you know medium-sized
I'm still employed by a medium-sized
company they had their rules I was
involved in groups they had their
expectations I self-censored you know
not 100 that's just impossible for me
but I self-centered a lot and I got
slapped on the wrist a lot and also more
heavily penalized but nothing like you
like you
I mean the traffic will bear you try to
do beyond what the traffic will bear and
then they tried to shut you down and
then as they say the internet use
censorship as damage and routes around
it
uh and so you know here we are
um well we've indicated
I wish I you've said a couple of things
now you've said history will record what
we did uh as correct and all of that I'm
less confident of this than you are in
part because I know
I believe
that we decisively won the first round
that there was a narrative that needed
to float and that narrative involved
there's nothing to do about covid
involving repurposed drugs the right
solution is vaccines they are safe and
effective yes maybe there will be some
side effects because there always are
but nothing significant cost benefit
analysis all of these things I believe
we decisively blew up their phony
narrative about covet Origins about
repurposed drugs and
repurposed drugs is still controversial
but yeah at least people are aware of
the question right and vaccine safety
and effectiveness
it however seems to be winning round two
because it's changed strategy instead of
trying to silence Us in an overt and
provable way it is now resorted to
interfering with our ability to reach
people and I think what it is doing is
it is keeping us isolated in
in a context where the people who can
hear us are already lost to them and new
people are not finding us at nearly the
rate that it uh
would make sense so anyway my point is
the inverse of this is sort of a dual to
audience capture it's not that Brett is
to giving a message and he's already got
his audience who believe his message and
the other people don't care to hear it
it is that uh they're kind of making
sure your audience stays captured as in
imprisoned and nobody else can get in or
out you know yeah it's a kind of it's a
kind of quarantine and I can tell you
it's not
subtle
from my chair
okay you can see it happen that is
different than being able to establish
it to somebody else's satisfaction when
they do not have the history they cannot
feel the change in various parameters
and therefore don't know whether you
have a misunderstanding of your own
significance or likability or relevance
or whatever
I can say interestingly I hope I hope
I'm entitled to say this
I had a discussion with Elon Musk and he
told me I think he's actually said this
elsewhere as well but he told me that
before he bought Twitter
he had the largest account or the most
interacted with account on Twitter
could feel in his account into the
meddling and now of course having bought
what he describes as a crime scene he
was in a position to find all of the
meddling and it's buried in ways that it
is not obvious it's not like you can
just turn those things off they're very
subtle so the fact that
he felt it and then
had the resources and insight that he
should purchase the thing and was able
to find those things says it is at least
not inconceivable that a person who is
suffering from this kind of meddling can
simply detect it and yes somebody could
make it up or somebody could lie to
themselves but what I'm telling you is
that we feel this very directly and it
is having
a huge impact I believe on how far we
can can reach it's still to this day and
uh obviously I mean if apparently even
with hunt what is it called uh Missouri
versus Biden which was to me like there
wasn't just a smoking gun that was like
that was like the Twitter files times
hundreds you know it was like they just
had
massive evidence of collusion between
the government they massive
evidence-based in government censorship
in all sorts of platforms
not just Twitter and
um you know what everybody knew that
there was Facebook files and YouTube
files and all this stuff even though
those companies were not revealing them
but then they did reveal them under the
discovery for this um
case and then there was that ruling
right that
allegedly you know that the court
forbade the government from
collaborating with social media
companies to alter um or promoted the
promote content I mean we'll see if
anyone you know to what extent that is
uh
enforced or whatever the right word is
followed but uh
I guess what I'm saying is so
even with that I guess even that the
government is supposed to have stopped
all this stuff you know you your
YouTube's not like offering to to uh
reinstate
you and and you're kind of am I correct
that you're still feeling um well it's
very interesting what's happened at
YouTube and I the pattern again is
absolutely conspicuous from my chair
I'm going to describe it to you
we
went far enough that they felt that they
could get away with demonetizing the
channel and I believe that their plan
was to kick us off the platform
they we had two channels we had 400 plus
thousand subscribers on each a main
channel on Eclipse Channel and
frankly
we were making money in a way that was
new to us
it lasted for one month
we did a live I did a live discussion
with Pierre Corey about the government
in question and then I did a live
podcast with Steve Kirsch and Robert
Malone I remember at the very end they
pulled both of those things they struck
the channel they set up the conditions
to remove us I believe they would have
accepted it if we had self-censored they
would have backed off and they would
have restored our ability to earn that's
I think what they wanted but failing
that they were perfectly ready to throw
us off and then Joe Rogan through what
he uh declared an emergency podcast he
held it an emergency podcast about the
situation and it resulted in YouTube
backing off entirely
the
the channel remains it is unmonetized
YouTube refuses to remonetize it but
conspicuously
the audience is completely static it was
absolutely skyrocketing before they
demonetized us and then it just it was
going up up up plateau and it's been
into Plateau ever since
so what that tells me is that they're
interfering that they have they zeroed
out more than half our family's income
and but here's the other part of the
pattern
we can say whatever we want
they don't strike the channel
so I think the point is you can say
whatever you want but but you think that
do you think people are actively like
how can I say this
are they actively not able to access
your videos or is it just that you're
for whatever reason your subscriber
comes the the Beast decides who sees
what it decides what to suggest when it
decides who to unsubscribe we don't know
the full right and it decides what to
tell us about who's watching it could be
that more people are seeing it than we
know but the numbers are artificially
flat it could be that it's being kept
from people it could be that there's a
target number that are allowed to see it
people who have already been lost
whatever so I don't know what the
pattern is but the idea that we derailed
a plan to get rid of us
by creating pain Joe Rogan created pain
it wasn't worth it to Google to admit
what they were doing as they would have
had to if they threw us off and so they
backed off their overt plan they block
our reach or our ability you know the
fact is the number of subscribers to the
channel dictates what it is that we can
earn if we've source
an Advertiser from outside of that
ecosystem the question is well how many
people can you reach so that number is
directly interfering with our ability to
earn it's an interesting thing you
described with YouTube is an example of
Scramble for the middle
yes well
um it is an intermediate solution I know
because insiders at Google have told me
that the decision about what to do with
our channel the decision not to
remonetize it was made in the c-suite
quite possibly by the CEO but certainly
in the c-suite so it was a top level
concern
and I think the other thing that people
perhaps don't quite understand is
this is a big Channel
but it's not a gigantic one so when I
say that we're being interfered with at
this level it sounds like a delusion of
grandeur on the other hand if you think
about what it is that actually happened
to the covet narrative
well who showed up on Dark Horse and
then went to Joe Rogan
right we had Pierre Corey we had Robert
Malone we had Peter McCullough so that
was uh
Darkhorse violated a sacred rule you
can't have two PhD biologists saying
actually this is complex but it's not as
complex as you think it is this is more
comprehensible than you know let's
unpack it let's talk about what the
actual facts of the disease are what the
actual facts of the therapy are what the
evidence really suggests where the
evidence seems to be phony
so we did that
and we talked to people who had been
targeted for dismissal
you on-ramped them onto Rogan who
couldn't be dismissed right now I I
don't I don't want to underrate what Joe
was doing yes Joe was paying attention
to Dark Horse and he listened to the
discussions with these folks but Joe is
an incredibly smart guy and very widely
read and he has an excellent
detector
he knew that this story wasn't making
sense and he knew what sense sounded
like sounds like Pierre Corey it sounds
like Robert Malone and when you look
into these people's backgrounds and you
hear they're supposed to be quacks and
then it turns out actually these are Top
Flight people in their fields with
impeccable credentials so I think the
point was you can't
the role that Dark Horse played in this
story was in its own way yeah maybe
on-ramp is is the right descriptor it's
a good one but the point is oh if we can
do away with the on-ramp that solves a
big problem and I believe that they've
decided to do away with the on-ramp and
you know we've I'm not complaining about
the quality of my life I live
wonderfully but
the interference with our family's
ability to earn the interference with my
ability to produce security for my
children in light of a very dangerous
world that's being made Dangerous by the
very people who are doing the
interfering is absolutely maddening it's
maddening I agree I find it maddening
and I'm not even
you know
running any sort of media
um
company or whatever we want to call it
entrepreneur be the entrepreneur thing
um this tells me I should have gone into
rocket science
oh I don't know about that I could I
would you know
I I'm not going to go into my personal
um
battles over all this stuff
let's just put it this way I was within
one day of being fired for being an
unvaccinated person who worked at a U.S
company with over 100 employees and then
the Supreme Court stepped in and said
I don't know
so you know
um that's as much as I'll say about it
um and so and then you know and to be
you know to be fair or like it's I can't
blame my company for this like this was
the law supposedly like they had to fire
me you know and um what are they going
to do close the company like a thousand
people because like three or four you
know contrarians no of course not and so
anyway it didn't happen thank goodness
for uh
the
um
Constitution
thank goodness for the Constitution
although
among the many
jaw-dropping facts of covid are the
number of people who could not find that
constitutional protection could not find
protection under Healthcare code right
healthcare workers right health care
workers members of the military
and that you know I I get stopped fairly
regularly
by people they with literally two
exceptions since Evergreen happened but
they say what people say in person is
always nice oh
um and
something that I have been hearing a lot
in the last
year is
thank you I did not get vaccinated
because you and Heather were making so
much sense on this topic and it gave me
the courage to resist
and every time I hear this I
I feel this powerful sense of having
done something right
to the the the the the danger of the
shots was so great that the idea that
there are people walking around out
there who
don't have to worry about the damage
that they did because we made sense to
them I don't know I I I'm I'm heartened
by it that's why I said and I think it's
only just begun when I say that history
will will in my estimation uh remember
you well I don't mean the history of the
next couple years what I mean is that
once there are dispassionate once people
once this is like
history and not present and I know
that's a loaded
term because who knows what road we're
headed down
with the inevitability of future
pandemics and all the other crises that
are being um promoted but uh
you know in the
eventually there will be Scholars who
will be mining all this stuff
and you know obscure videos on like
former platforms that no longer exist
it's going to be like historical gold
and and I think I think
the truth will prevail you know I want
to mention one thing
um
Robert Anton Wilson I don't know if you
know who he is he's the lady sure yeah
he he said something about In Praise
that the constitution he said um
the US Constitution
may not be perfect but it's a hell of a
lot better than what we've got
um
and uh he also wrote this book the thing
that ate the Constitution this was
written many years ago and long before
covid and uh he um there's a quote which
hopefully I'll find to read to from
there but he describes a mad Czar of
Medicine
who is
controlling things and he's like how did
we go from having a constitution to
having a mad Czar in control
of our health policies who's ruining
everything and this was like in the 90s
that he said this
so I've been marveling on this too and
there's a biological analogy that just
I can't escape it
in fact probably the right person to
talk to about it are our doctors
critical care doctors okay
when a person is healthy
you don't notice their physiology it
just kind of hums along
and
when something gets knocked sufficiently
far out of whack right their health
collapses yeah right systems that are
dependent on each other
I started coming apart and so I think we
were like a
a nation
I'm loathed to describe our system as
healthy anytime in my lifetime
but it was healthy enough
that it worked and then something in
recent decades
was dislodged just far enough that
things became possible here
that although I in the abstract knew
they were possible all along I did not
expect to see it I assume they were
impossible yeah right like for instance
large-scale Mass uh censorship uh across
the board like um
you know failures of the biological kind
um yeah oh no I agree yeah
the harming of children yes right based
on
erroneous beliefs about gender
yes that's a whole other topic I want to
ask I want to though
ask you as an evolutionary biologist
what you think of this because I I was
shocked
covid was the major shock but as I've
mentioned there were shocks to me before
about other
Health advice from the authorities that
as far as I could tell was 180 degrees
wrong like at almost every time I looked
I mean I guess don't smoke cigarettes
was they would write about that
eventually but um uh so
then during covet what I found and I
like you have a rather what I consider a
very intelligent and I thought
open-minded Social Circle
and whoever was very close to still am
but what shocked me was that even
amongst the very intelligent and
seemingly open-minded Social Circle
uh
so many of that group which kind of
mirrored the population at large if you
will in some ways so many of that group
totally bought the narrative
and even tried to
um suppress or discourage any contrarian
voices
from even uh speaking now that was weird
because I had always been a kind of
contrarian voice in my community on all
sorts of different things and people
like loved me for it they were like put
Creon on that one you know he'll tear
down he's like a bulldog like he'll
he'll figure out what's buried and um
and this used to be like one of my
superpowers that people uh engaged with
and utilized
hardly alone in this
but uh right many contrarians and sort
of intellectuals go on these
rabbit holes or whatever you want to
call them but uh then with kovid
I guess because everyone was so afraid
primarily uh people were like you know
shut shut the up like you're gonna
kill us all like that sort of thing now
so then I was wondering I was like okay
why am I a contrarian because I've kind
of been that way most of my life you
know rebellious little kid you know in
college I was always arguing for a while
I thought it was contrarian because I
like to argue and I like to be right but
I mean I didn't become a lawyer became
an engineer basically and in engineering
you argue but it's a mark of respect
like you argue with your colleagues
because you're trying to come up with
the best solution and so you know
Finding flaws in their in their design
or their analysis is is a is like that's
why you're together in the first place
on the team anyway I don't like to argue
particularly I don't even like to be
right I certainly don't like to be
polarized against my friends and I don't
like to be that guy who's like always
got the like I don't want that to be why
what people think of me he's the guy
he's always going to take the other side
you know why but why am I contrarian if
it's not those things
and then I kind of came to the
you know I had a lot of time to
self-reflect on this while I was kind of
isolated both physically and and
socially during the lockdowns and I was
like thinking
here's what it is the reason I'm a
contrarian is because I have a lot of
smart friends and if all my smart
friends are over here exploring this
territory kind of near the middle of the
bell curve if you will
I want to go out on the tail one tail or
the other why do I want to go down the
tail I know that I'm unlikely that it's
like kind of arguably unlikely that you
find something out on the tail that's
really of interest but at least
everybody else isn't searching out there
at least it's Virgin Territory
so I was like that's why I like to do it
because I don't really feel like I'm
it's not like I'm some genius who's
going to go where everybody else is
looking and find something amazing like
probably not my you know hack is to go
look where people aren't looking to some
extent so that I was kind of happy with
that and then this is where it gets into
evolutionary biology where I want your
opinion and then I was like well what
explains that like 90 of my
Circle and 90 of everybody just walked
along with the narrative and what I was
thinking was you know it's got to be
that way from evolutionary perspective
because Proto because early prehistoric
tribe of humans
you got to follow the leader if you
don't follow the leader it's not a tribe
like if everybody's doing their own
thing they can't be any Collective
action hunting you know whatever they
have to do like you have to have
leadership and it has to be followed and
that's what gets selected for except you
probably also select for a small
fraction of people
who are Renegades because if you don't
if they don't go out literally and
explore
other places and other ideas and kind of
go off on their own
nothing's ever going to change nothing's
ever going to advance so I think we have
an evolutionary equilibrium where most
people follow the leader and some people
don't and it may have been selected for
what do you think about that
yeah I feel certain that this unfolds in
many related ways
I've used the example of
the guy
you imagine somebody 500 years ago
who noticed in the shimmering of the
Aspen leaves something that implied a
binary encoding of the world right they
might be triggered to notice the way a
particular Leaf went from light to dark
in the wind and they might think I
wonder
I wonder how much we could we could load
into a on off
it wouldn't be wrong right they would be
hundreds of years ahead of their time
and so on the one hand good show it's
great to be able to see things that are
deeply in the future
on the other hand you could imagine
somebody who couldn't help themselves
and was doing that on a battlefield were
doing that during uh famine when you
should be hunting right and the point is
no cut it out what we're doing is this
other thing and don't do that so there
there is a legitimate argument for this
is not the place for that this is not
the place for contrarianism this is not
the place for uh
speculation this is the place to do
something else
so we are always caught in bind when
something says this is not the place for
that it may be that that's true or it
may be oh this is actually exactly the
place for that
this is not the time to question vaccine
safety and Effectiveness really you've
just introduced something it doesn't
even appear to match the definition of
the term vaccine right it's based on a
brand new technology and it's never been
demonstrated uh to function and you
haven't had very long to test it you're
telling me this isn't the time to
question whether it's a good idea to
inject that I think it's exactly the
time well so it's fair enough I mean I
hear you
um but I mean if we can't we even say
like look at Warfare like we're going to
war you know you don't have a choice
like it's not good for your health you
know it's even worse for your health
than some crazy new drug right that
hasn't been tested like going to war is
probably going to be very bad for your
health but you're going you know this is
the collective action of the group I
mean that's sort of the extreme example
of it societies do this and to some
extent they've been selected maybe not
so much recently to uh
to do this but some people are going to
Desert and some people are gonna you
know be pacifists and so it it's
probably good that we have those people
around at least I'd like to think so
since
and you can have you know presumably a
well-adjusted person knows when not to
do such things as the ship is sinking
it's not the time to be thinking about
where the failures in its design may
have been it's the desire to think about
how to preserve life right but some
people are going to be prone to keeping
their head down and doing their job and
other people are going to be prone to
figuring out what jobs might be done
that would be useful that we're not
thinking to do so there's a natural
division there I do want to push back a
little bit on your idea of contrarianism
okay I've been dismissed
Heather and I have both been dismissed
as contrarian in fact people who
were reaching the Judgment that we had
been incorrect based on nothing at all
have told us what went wrong the reason
you got this wrong is that you were used
to
being a contrarian and being right and
so you just did it reflexively now by
the way I don't want to interrupt you
except to say so people that we would
dismiss as conformists dismissed you as
a contrarian I think that's right
now what I would say is I don't I don't
even the word contrarian has no
positive connotation to me in fact it
has a negative one the word the word
dissident
has a positive connotation because a
dissident is somebody with the courage
to stand up against a regime in general
that's a regime that needs someone to
stand up against it but what I think
happened to me and what I suspect I hope
you'll upgrade your term for yourself as
well yes I do tend to look for
unlikely possibilities because even
though most of the unlikely
possibilities that you entertain you
have to throw out because they're not
right right when you find something and
you are more likely to find something
rather than searching where everybody
else is looking it can be useful and you
know exhilarating
but what I try to do
I I live Downstream
of a very strong distaste for being
wrong
I really don't like it and
you could in fact we've seen some
important examples of people who have
some fraction of that they don't like
being wrong so what they do is when they
are wrong they bend over backwards not
to see it
I don't do that I try when I'm wrong to
get to fix my thinking as quickly as
possible so I don't have to spend time
any more time in that wrong space than
necessary so what that means is
I'm looking a I'm not looking to find
out what everybody else thinks is true
because it is certainly possible for
everybody else to be wrong and I don't
want to get led into being wrong because
I'm following everybody else so I want
to go first principles and figure out is
that likely to be right
what's bugging me about it I want to do
my homework there and what I would say
is this becomes
indistinguishable from contrarianism in
an era where Society is for whatever
reason reflexively wrong
right covid we got everything wrong
publicly that means that if what you
were doing is spotting
we meaning the big we got it wrong not
you and me civilization told you exactly
the wrong things to do it told you
exactly the wrong origin story for the
virus it got everything upside down
so it doesn't make you a contrarian if
you disagreed on everything
it means that you were doing your own
work and that this was actually
deducible if you could overcome the
social pressure to conform yes I don't I
don't feel like a contrarian if I feel
like if we had gotten it all right
I would have been on board with it oh
sure yeah
it's not it's not contrarianism for me
this is all related it's related to you
know the the guys on the side of
censorship never turn out to be the good
guys it's like how many points do we
have to learn this lesson so
um I'm fully with you uh on that I like
the idea of dissident uh instead of
contrarian
um and thanks thanks for that um
let me see
oh
so
so are you gonna
so how can I say this
I'm not sure what more I can
do on this I thought for a while that I
could advocate for setting up these
failure investigation board accident
investigation board I'm a little bit
and I pitched that into a lot of people
you know important people rich people
influential people and now it's kind of
like
yeah with this with this with the
Scramble for the middle and this kind of
everybody's chosen their side it's going
to be very hard do you
um and so what you're doing continuing
to speak the truth or at least make an
honest effort to find the truth and see
what and speak what you find
um
what
there's got to be something in the
middle though between uh
individual voices and
the collective action that seems to not
be happening
well
I have argued I'm not alone in this I've
seen other people say something similar
but
wisdom is almost synonymous with delayed
gratification
that wisdom is almost always the triumph
over a longer term style of thinking a
longer term reward structure you know
I'm going to exercise today because I
will feel better six months from now if
I do that every day I will suffer in the
short term but in the long term the
reward will be even greater
people are at the moment
treating from a recognition of how many
errors they made how many places they
were misled
how much damage they may have done
and I get it
if that had been me it would be a very
hard place to look in the mirror wait oh
you mean if it had been you uh creating
if if I had gone along with the
narrative and had discovered at this
late date that the vaccines were not
safe they weren't effective there were
other treatments the disease didn't come
from where I thought it had come from
the variants were in fact induced by the
inoculation campaign all of that if I
had been on board with the public
narrative rather than spotting its
defects I would be
I believe I wouldn't have ended up in
that situation but if I had my instinct
would cause me to look at it how could
that possibly have happened but I think
the point that needs to be made to
people who are retreating from looking
at themselves in the mirror and figuring
out what what defects were taken
advantage of to get them on board
the point is
if you could go back
and you could unvaccinate yourself hmm
huge fraction of people who got these
shots would do it
the point is
there's a part of you that's saying it
doesn't matter because you can't do that
but you can save your future self your
future self is going to be it may not be
a shot next time but your future self is
going to be exposed to similar
it's going to be coerced in similar ways
and the way to save your future self is
to to have an accounting of what
happened this time so this is not in
that case the accounting is not so much
about the particulars it's about the
general flaws in our society and
ourselves that allowed this particular
set of particulars to dominate
in the narrative and will presumably
unfortunately allow the next set of CR
Panic crisis coercion uh to to dominate
and it's like it's hard because it's not
like people waking up about treatments
or any of these things it's about people
waking up to their own
uh
their own high are you genetic
propensity to follow the leader that's a
hard thing to wake up from
it's a hard thing to wake up from but
I mean if you could see the look in
people's eyes when they tell me
I didn't get those shots because of what
you said the point was
there I mean and I'm a little
embarrassed I I'm not sure we could have
done better we we threaded a needle
remaining we could have
Gone full bore every platform from the
first moments it was obvious right and
if we had it would have been a very
short ride so could we have reached more
people with a more
direct message I don't know but
there was a way to save yourself from
this some people had more power to do it
because
their job allowed it
and some people didn't have uh sure that
freedom
but in any case what I would what I
would suggest is
we are as I said to people early in the
pandemic we are never going to get a
better shot in our lifetime at figuring
out what has gone wrong with our system
than coffee
I love that that positive spin that's
fantastic thank you this is the best
shot we're ever going to get and so in
light of that
do you really want to have to go through
another one of these in order to get
another data set this is the data set
right this is the data set that allows
us to see it and if we're ever going to
fix it this is the one that we should
proceed from and that is why I'm still
on this topic
we've been inoculated we'll see if it
still see if it's effective yeah we have
uh we have uh natural immunity on this
topic having bought it at a very high
price
I have old old friend
I've known for 48 years
a newer when she was a little girl
she's a classical French horn player
she's like
you know at the top of her career her
husband is a classical French horn
player they're both at the peak level of
their careers playing professional
Orchestra uh they were um
the orchestra mandated vaccination they
refused
uh
didn't mandate vaccination for the
audiences by the way just for the
players and um
and so they both uh chose to be fired
from and if you can imagine how rare it
is for these two people to be playing in
the same Orchestra with the same skills
and be married and then you know their
livelihood was taken away and they
um
you know they're making it work but uh
what was shocking to me actually
was that their you their you know dudes
paying members of The Musicians Union
for all these years and what did the
Musicians Union do it's cited on the
management I was like well we're not
gonna We're Not Gonna
help you with a legal battle against the
orchestra
it's just it it shows so much that's
wrong
hey it's not like this is people dying
and stuff like that but you know it's
closed it's people's livelihood both of
their livelihoods kind of like you and
Heather
so it reveals an interesting feature of
the pattern when Heather and I had our
bizarre eviction from Evergreen where we
were teaching
our Union also sided with management oh
really yeah uh it's a it's a feature of
this of this puzzle and it has a lot to
do with how you end up in dissident
space it's kind of like it's kind of
like
journalists siding with the government
it's a similar sort of uh exactly
it is that Unholy Alliance that tells
you you're not where you think you are
right exactly
um I would also point out
we have an example
that is part of our not our daily lives
but our weekly lives here up in the San
Juan Islands the San Juan Islands are
islands off the state of Washington that
are served by state fairies and the
state fairies are marvelous they're
right a joy and it's wonderful that they
exist in all of the infrastructure is
there and it's been a part of the state
of Washington for I don't know how long
the
these are car fairies
the governor
uh who is actually the same world-class
dimwit who his office is seven miles
from Evergreen and he as far as I know
still has not mentioned the debacle that
happened there absolutely refused to
call in any help even though you know
seven miles from his office students
were roving the campus with weapons uh
battering each other hunting professors
but anyway that same genius who failed
to do anything about that episode
fired all of the people who refused
vaccination or so-called vaccination who
were part of the ferry system
still has not rehired them and the ferry
system went from being this highly
reliable mechanism for getting from the
mainland to the islands and back into
something that is now completely
unreliable fairies are routinely being
canceled because of mechanical failures
because of lack of crew and it it's a
daily reminder that for some reason
these people felt entitled to purge
people these were people who were
largely working Outdoors yeah right on
ferries who were no threat to anyone and
not only were they fired which is uh
incredible but they haven't been rehired
even though civilization has moved on
from prioritizing this or thinking that
the vaccines were any kind of solution
at all
yeah well part of the war on meritocracy
and competence and you know
it's like
get rid of the dissidents
you know absolutely like we don't send
them to the gulag anymore but we we do
this we do the best we can well we have
a we have a diffuse Gulag where they can
interrupt if you're a French horn player
you can suddenly find yourself out of
work and I don't know what a French horn
player does when the tiny number of
French horn playing positions
are mandated to go to people who have
shown compliance
they do chamber music with less
management uh and uh they do um
alternative career paths
but where is where is the Reckoning that
causes all of the people who turned out
to be right that this was not society's
right to mandate these things because
they had no capacity to prevent the
spread of the disease when do all these
people get restored to their former
positions when do they get an apology
that they were ever thrown out of work
that they were threatened when does that
happen
well
it's an interesting question I mean we
can we can point to all sorts of uh
past societal wrongs and we can
certainly think of people who are like
saying when are we going to get an
apology you know is The Usual Suspects
right but but there's plenty of
unfortunately sorry for the background
noise unfortunately there's plenty of um
there's plenty of
precedent for apologies being
if they come at all being Generations
down the line
um you know
that I'm not sure that that has to be
true and I would point out
that the
apology and I don't know this history
perfectly well I hope I don't make an
error but the apology that Galileo got
from the Catholic church and the apology
uh the acknowledgment that Darwin got
that
uh Evolution was more than just a theory
and that it had an explanatory role in
describing the the Origin of Species
these things came close together in time
which means that Darwin's apology was on
a fast track so I'm not sure that we
haven't something about our
informational environment hasn't changed
in a way that these things could come a
lot faster and should come a lot faster
well I think I I appreciate your
positive uh take on it and I think
that's uh that's actually quite likely
and we might see it I mean
oh
the Gap has been closing arguably like
Germany apologized for all sorts of
things you know it took a generation but
at least it didn't take 10. right yep
um and so maybe and that was you know
pre
internet by and large so yeah well I
appreciate your your your your positive
look at it hey do we want to Pivot and
move on to some uh other profits I was
gonna suggest it uh there are many
things we could discuss we could discuss
AI we could discuss SpaceX uh there are
lots of topics on which we have mutual
interests what do you think
um
well speaking of SpaceX this my my data
is coming to you via starlink
and so far we haven't had the Dropout so
that's that's very nice don't
I don't want to jinx it but um yeah I
I've switched over and never went back
by the way and let's tie it together
here I used to have you know cable
broadband like everyone else in the in
the desert suburbs where I reside and um
but when Starling I have a group of
friends who work
run and work together on a property uh
in Northern California and
we have connections so we got one of the
very first Starlight terminals that was
available for anybody it was gifted To
Us by a man who you've met and um
and so once I saw how good it was even
three and a half years ago when the
constellation was quite sparse compared
to what it is now
I was like well as soon as it's
available to me I'm going to get it and
so it took a it took another
two years or so before I got you know I
got on to starlink right before it like
showed up and I mean a couple six months
before it showed up in Home Depot and
all this kind of stuff like now it's
everywhere and everybody's got it but
anyway I was like this was during the
height of censorship and I was like if
I'm going to have an internet service
provider I want it to be
run by this guy whose so-called Free
Speech absolutist whether it's you know
let's just believe him right and like
that's who I want my ISP to be because I
was like
look it is technically within the
uh it is technically within the
capabilities of your internet service
provider to decide that um
packets to this destination are you know
that's it's like it's like the red
firewall of China they can just say oh
you want to go to uh
are you guys on Rumble right
oh yeah Rumble yeah you can't you can't
send and receive packets from Rumble
you're living in the the 15-minute City
we don't allow that you know and so I'm
like thank you I'll take a channel to
the sky
you know uh uh run by a free speech
absolutist because although it can also
be censored it's probably going to be
the last to go
yeah I agree uh the the vulnerabilities
are many and a direct channel to the sky
uh as you point out owned by a
self-described free speech absolutist is
a better bet to be sure
and I actually think I wrote about this
I don't write that much but I wrote
about this on substack which is I think
he's got a plan I think if you if you
look at elon's
um
three years his his strategies like
okay what did he do he's got a he's got
a um
a sustainable energy and transport
Tesla both the vehicles and the Energy
Systems
he's got
you know humans to space
the Mars multi-planetary thing SpaceX
obviously that's the vision and they're
doing other things along the way to make
to make the business sustainable
then he goes and makes a
relatively uncensorable internet
backbone
it's politically sensorable because like
you have to get permission from certain
countries too
if you're going to be radio in and out
of a country technically you need that
country's permission I mean you don't
need it physically but uh like
anyway
so uncensorable Communications
sustainable energy access to space
neural links like another whole kettle
of fish but let's just say that that's a
play to merge humans in AI rather than
just have ai running the entire show
I'll give them the benefit of that on
that one and now uh
uh yeah unsensible internet and now
Twitter and people are like well Twitter
is the odd one here like what does that
have to do with any of these things and
I think it's actually all of his stuff
is dedicated it seems to me or can be
viewed can be steel manned as
dedicated to human progress and and
Twitter was kind of like part of the
central nervous system
of the human
uh
Collective and it was arguably uh
uh diseased
and so he bought it to do surgery on
part of our central nervous system to
like rid us at least a large part of
certain
um disease States that had taken over
this information conduit and was
blocking information so I kind of view
all this stuff as
roughly coherent
I agree with you there is a coherence
it's a little hard to distinguish
between good bets
and an overarching plan
the you know the the case of the boring
company for example
it's not obvious that this is a solution
to the actual problem that was described
that the problem of traffic is best
solved by
creating space underground there's
there's lots of you can make as many
lanes as you want underground but it is
a very good technology to have in your
quiver for all sorts of foreseeable
future scenarios
right it's it's a mining technology it
could be coupled with other planetary uh
Tech and Etc but
let's go back to Twitter for a second
I do think there is I would say that
Twitter is as close to the locus of
collective human consciousness as we've
got
and it was if disease is not the right
term something in that neighborhood it
was clearly broken in the sense that
if you're going to have a technological
Locus for Consciousness that locusts
can't have an opinion of its own
if it has an opinion of its own then it
it it doesn't allow you to conclude what
should be concluded the way a
Consciousness must so I love the idea of
freeing that thing from whatever the the
ghost in the machine was and I find it
interesting that musk is struggling with
the process of freeing it there are
really two parts of that struggle one
you can't have a total free-for-all in
which people violate the law
through uh
you have to deploy some mechanism
for making judgments about what is and
is not tolerated on the platform
Free Speech absolutist or not
so that's a problem and then there's the
question of all of the entities with
various levels of capacity who wish to
shape our Collective Consciousness as
we've just seen them do with covet
convincing the public on mass of things
that simply were not the case so that
they will behave on the basis of those
things
Twitter is one of the places where that
happened and Twitter is what you know I
as you know I've
said zero is a special number which is
to say if you have a single platform in
which adults can actually have a
conversation in which all relevant
points of view are voiced in every other
platform sensors then of course all
adults will want to be on the platform
where they can have the conversation
that has to be had so that's the it has
the number of platforms that work has to
be zero which is why all of the effort
has been spent to derail musk to
to drive people from the platform
so anyway I think it's a
a noble effort a valuable effort and
that we really should think of it in
terms of
the manifestation the most useful
manifestation of human human Collective
Consciousness that we've got
because if it isn't Twitter what is it
well I mean if we got the uh censorship
industrial complex uh cleaned out of
some of the other platforms then it
would also be them like YouTube is a
fantastic resource if you want to learn
how to fix your dishwasher or you know
and your garden
certain places they've decided are
to you know they decided for whatever
silly reasons to censors maybe some
a sense of porn they censor this and
they censor you you know so they make
bad decisions
or somebody's forcing them to make bad
decisions I could imagine
house cleaning and that becoming part of
our Collective Consciousness or a better
it already is part of it but like
becoming more of it I mean we have
substack you know we have um it's like
the it's like the internet is kind of
got a bit of its former glory still you
know yeah and it's it's uh it's
reformulating which I think is fantastic
I think that that has to happen because
the regime we were living under was so
oppressive should we uh pivot further
over you have a long history in AI most
of us I've have
I have never officially worked in that
realm I've been thinking about it enough
that I I wrote a piece in
um what would have been 2016 about it
so anyway you and I have shared interest
in this space but you certainly know a
lot more at the professional and
Technical level than I do so tell us
what you think where are we
first of all before I start
pontificating about AI I want to come
clean about my long history in AI my
long history in AI is as an interested
person for since the 1980s
I was maybe even a little before like I
read
the original books by Minsky and stuff
like that when I was in high school but
when I became a young professional I had
access to the NASA Library which is
quite good the NASA Ames library and um
and I would read everything I could find
that came into the library uh
or that I could dig through in the
stacks on uh AI particularly neural Nets
which were considered just so pass a
back then it's like well everybody knows
neural and that's that's not how you do
AI you do a logic and
databases and
declarative programming like neurons
that they thought that was going to work
in the 1960s it didn't turn out so but I
always thought they were cool and so I
kept reading about them and thinking
about them and playing with programs but
I never it's not like I published an AI
it's not like I'm some kind of a machine
learning Professor I used
some amount of machine learning and
other techniques to do data analysis at
Nasa over the years
um to varying degrees of success
mostly I found data visualization to be
more useful than machine learning back
um in the 90s and early 2000s and such
um
sort of using my own biological learning
to analyze data rather than relying on
just statistical classifiers and stuff
like that but then of course the AI
winter ended and the uh deep learning
Revolution became came came along I
would like to say I saw that coming
because I remember when back propagation
was first discovered and I was like okay
well this changes things but it then we
had to have like giant data and giant
computers and now now we are where we
are and so you ask where are we and I
just want to make sure clear that I was
sort of an interested person
mathematically literate computer science
literate
but not like a contributor to this field
all right caveat accepted
so so where are we now is what I where I
think we are is you know um we're at an
interesting place
uh I am now working on some projects in
this area as you might guess because I
work for a satellite imaging data
company we
build and launch and operate satellites
and then our product is the data images
of the earth that we bring down from
these satellites and so we bring down a
Titanic amount of data like many
terabytes a day and so to some extent
nobody can look at all that and so if
you want to know about what's going on
and what's not going on and what's
changing and what's you know what's
happening you have to arguably use
computer vision
and so I'm heavily involved in that kind
of stuff right now more I used to design
telescopes and and camera systems and
satellite uh
systems like what they call systems
engineering where you combine the
different subsystems like propulsion you
payload and power and comms anyway
then I recently kind of have like oh
I've had enough I've been doing
satellite engineering and payload
engineering for a number
like nine years now I'm gonna go back
into software for a while and so working
on some some really great people on some
software projects but they're mostly
focused on Vision Machine Vision image
understanding that sort of thing I'm
just going to leave it at that because
it's kind of early stage somewhat
proprietary stuff at this point
um and there's lots of people working on
this kind of thing I mean
it's not like we're great pioneers we're
just trying to apply it to our own
unique data source which is all these
terabytes of satellite imagery
and um
so that's very interesting to me but
that's not what most people mean when
they say where are we at in AI they may
know what about the large language
models and GPT n plus one and all this
kind of stuff and um I think we're at a
fairly interesting place but I don't
know that it is so
profound as a lot of people think
um and I've certainly and could probably
even repeat your you made these like an
augmented list of AI dangers that goes
beyond the standard AI risks and talks
about
um sort of risks to people's cognitive
apparatus and risks to our social Fabric
and things that is not
the classic AI risks of paper clips and
so I know your position on that roughly
speaking
um
and I agree although I would have to say
that
you know this is what was supposed to be
wrong with social media and this was
supposed to be what was wrong with
television before it's like it's it's
gonna corrupt the bangs of the youth and
it's there's going to be scams I mean I
don't know if you've ever read this book
called The Victorian Internet it's
fascinating it came out in the
early 2000s I believe
uh it's one of my favorite books it
talks about the telegraph Network
so the Victorian era trans first
eventually International Communication
System that enabled instant
Communications I mean this was the thing
this was like nuclear energy it was like
all of a sudden Communications became a
million times as fast you used to have
to take weeks to send something by ship
documents that was the only way to get
information across the Atlantic and that
or the oceans and then
within a fairly short time cables were
strong before wireless radio
cables were strung and information could
travel effectively
instantly
like let's say say it's a million times
faster like this is a step change and
everyone was very excited about it and
you know it was
interesting to see what it was used for
before it was used for anything else so
uh was used for Warfare of course
because fast Communications gives you
decisive advantage and it was used for
people to arrange um
secret love affairs and like Rich
business people to arrange for their
Mistresses to be in the right place at
the right time so basically porn and War
just like the current Internet anyway
wonderful I wouldn't call it I wouldn't
call that porn but I get your point it
was used for like
sex and yeah there you go okay
Saxon violins
as they like to say um anyway uh so uh
yeah so what am I saying here so
everyone was like up in arms because
obviously this was the this was going to
destroy civilization you know
because it enabled these kinds of high
efficiency disruption of you know the
old ways of War and the old ways of love
and
and then you just see this repeat I
guess my point is every time there's a a
breakthrough in
or change step change in information you
know radio television
email social media and now
language models it's like
okay I guess you know eventually you
pull a black ball from the urn as they
say and the fact that you hold on
I'm going to disagree with you
the internet
is going to destroy civilization
did it
I don't know but we are at a place where
civilization is facilitating the
medical disfigurement of children on the
basis of a faulty
unscientific model of gender
we have lost
our once
universally held belief that pedophilia
is bad
we are
now questioning fundamental logic at the
level of whether one or two plus two
necessarily equals four oh wait it
doesn't cost because we're white right
but anyway
um what what'd you say I said it does
for us because we're white isn't that
the argument I don't know what the
argument is but I guess my point would
be I think the idea that
lots of people have looked at television
the internet Etc
and decided that it's going to destroy
us and that it hasn't happened it might
not be right because I don't know that
it isn't actually happening we're seeing
something in which the most fundamental
agreements at the heart of our
civilization are now not just under
scrutiny but are universally being
rejected every single value is now under
threat simultaneously so
I don't know what did it
him we still man the opposition here
sure
or as I guess that's a fancy way first
thing let me argue with you let me push
back even though I'm not necessarily
believe everything I sure say but it's
it's not like I totally just leave it up
okay we have had panics and fevers in
the figurative sense and The Madness of
crowds
and
uh you know Mania is a very group
civilizational manias of All Sorts from
probably before written history but
certainly this like this kind of crazy
rejection of what was believed to be
universally acknowledged this has
happened before people have been swept
away by craziness and you know
pendulum swings back and forth and
different people have different ideas of
what's crazy and what's not I think the
pendulum probably has I'd have to agree
with you it's it's swung too far in the
directions that you're complaining about
but you know one might argue that it was
too far in the other direction before
where like nobody was allowed to
question anything about gender and no
one was allowed to you know
explore so yeah I have a feeling don't
you think that there's a chance that
that we're gonna
converge or do you think the
oscillations are undamped and getting
Wilder
he's a little hard to say
because oscillation itself is an
imprecise term that's hard to map onto
this landscape but
of course I think there is a chance that
we will come to our senses I wouldn't be
taking the kinds of risks that I'm
taking for myself or for my family if I
didn't think there was a decent chance
that we could
put us back on course but I do think
that no argument that is based on the
fact that people have
feared
the implications of technological
especially informational change in the
past and been wrong is
has the justifiable presumption of Truth
at this point because
there comes a point there are certain
topics two plus two equals four
is not an interesting topic because it's
so fundamental that no rational person
would seriously challenge it the idea
that pedophilia is something we need to
rethink because something something
something
no this is not something you rethink the
idea that doctors not only should be
allowed to hack apart
perfectly healthy young people rendering
them incapable and medically dependent
for the rest of their lives but that
anybody
who gets between a child and such a
doctor is guilty of some sort of a moral
failing we are talking about
a
decoherence that is so profound
that I think the presumption goes in the
exact opposite direction we are watching
civilization come apart in a way
that we don't have
good examples of civilizations
recovering from this level of insanity
do we
well I'm not a historian and I'm you
know I I don't really know what I'm
talking about here I tend
I I hope that you're wrong of course I'm
not saying that you're wrong in your
claims I hope that you're wrong in your
projections
um and uh right the fact that no the
fact that no civilization has rescued
itself from this level of insanity
doesn't mean we can't again that's the
only reason that I'm doing what I'm
doing well also I tend to think that
like
I tend to think
we might be
um I don't know if this is true but
aren't
isn't there a danger like the filter
bubble danger like isn't there the
danger of uh like how common is all are
all these crazinesses and all these
failings just because
like man bites dog you know what I mean
it's that sort of a thing isn't it no it
is not such a thing Creon and we can
tell that because
where is the University where
they say no
a child who is gender non-conforming not
only is not in need of some sort of
medical intervention but it would be
immoral to engage in it where is that
University
I do not know I mean we're now going to
get into the yeah so maybe this is
what's more concerning uh and I know
this is near and dear to you what's more
concerning to me is that Academia is
falling apart it's well but but I I
wasn't going to stop with Academia
where's the the newspaper yeah which
this is plainly stated
there are a few of those newspapers but
you know there there are a few maybe
maybe
and they would be censored if uh if if
the uh other newspapers had their way
but I don't know where is the major
scientific journal in which these things
are simply rejected
I see them embraced in top tier journals
there are a couple of exceptions but my
point would be if this was a matter of
filter bubbles
and focusing on something that is very
localized and isolated and small and
imagining that it extends to the whole
it wouldn't be the majority of journals
it wouldn't be all of the universities
it wouldn't be the majority of
newspapers it would be the rare
newspaper and we would debate whether or
not the fact that some newspaper was
saying these things was an ominous sign
about the future but it clearly is much
more Global than is
tolerable
we are headed in that direction I will I
will um this is a place kind of like
maybe rocketry or something like this
like this is a focused interest of yours
that I don't know that much about so I'm
just gonna have to refer to your
expertise on it because I'm not sure I
can you know cogently uh Riff on it that
much
um but one thing I don't want to know is
uh historically and again I'm not a
historian but this seems to be when we
talk about these institutions the press
the journals the academias
um
I forgot which was the the other one you
said medicine you know it's like the
elites I don't mean Elites like the you
know
the trilateral commissioner is kind of
conspiracy Elites I mean like Elite
classes of Society of High professionals
the well-educated it it's a Madness that
seems to be mostly infecting them is it
not like Working Class People don't have
time for this do they
well that's an interesting question I
don't my impression is that there is
less focus on it but that if the elites
are setting the Rules of Engagement
that it is not that there is that
medicine for Working Class People is
humming along the way it used to and
medical medicine for the elites is
suffering from some sort of a delusion
medicine is suffering from a delusion
right and that means it's reaching
everyone
whether
yeah so
anyway I mean look this this is a
diversion
from your central point which is
we have a new technology new
technologies come with dangers those
dangers are often misunderstood until
years after these things have been
deployed so maybe we're not where we
think we are well isn't there that I
forget who's eponym gets applied to it
but it's like there's that law that we
tend to overestimate the near-term
effects of any new technology and
underestimate the long-term effects of
that same technology and so everyone
who's worried that like we're going to
have fast AI take off and you know wake
up one morning uh to AI overlords making
turning us into paper clips I think you
know I know that's kind of a ridiculous
version of it but I tend to think that
you know those people are going to be
disappointed just like they are going to
be disappointed with room temperature
superconductors and humans to Mars and
all these things in the short term I
mean when I was a kid I thought it was
we were going to have fusion and it'll
be living on the moon and you know all
this stuff was obvious to me by the time
I was an adult this was going to be a
done deal and it's like ah the world has
kind of pretty much like it was when I
was a kid except that we've got you know
we've got internet and we've got you
know a few other things but I mean
uh I guess what I'm saying is that so I
think that in the long term AI might be
a very potent
to change
to our culture just like computers and
electricity and all these other
breakthroughs before them but in the
short term I'm not quite sure that uh
I don't know I don't know I don't you
know because I've done a fair amount I'm
not an expert but I've done a fair
amount of experimentation with some of
the larger llm products as well as some
of the smaller ones and I have to say
that um
you know about the term galman Amnesia
yeah I do
yeah for people who don't
yeah so as I understand Gelman and
Amnesia was named after Murray Gelman
who either claimed or was known to
you know read an article in the
newspaper or magazine about
physics because he was a physicist Nobel
Prize winner created the concept of
quarks and a bunch of other things he
would read an article about physics in
like Scientific American or the
newspaper Time Magazine and he'd be like
well they got that totally wrong like
this they got everything wrong in that
article pretty much that you could
possibly get wrong and then he turned
the next article which was a about
something you didn't know about and he
would just accept it as probably true
and this is sort of the idea of the
general phenomenon that you know when we
scrutinize the mass media in somewhere
that we're an expert it's very easy to
find flaws but then we forget that those
same types of flaws may be Universal in
uh or far too common and popularizations
and uh anyway so I kind of get a Gelman
Amnesia effect from the large language
models if I ask them about something
that I really know
they don't do a very good job they get a
lot of things wrong they miss important
stuff sometimes they're like completely
wrong
and you know maybe occasionally I find
something useful but that's hard to find
something useful because I'm already an
expert we would have to be more expert
than me but it gets stuff wrong
and then when I ask it about stuff I
don't know about
it sounds quite plausible
and I'm very impressed
you're also looking at it in the very
earliest phase
okay which you know to your point about
long-term effects being
more interesting than the short-term
impact here now as you know although I
think the possibility of misaligned AI
is real it's not where my concern is
focused I'm much more focused on the
types of disaster that I believe are
certain to flow from what we've already
seen and can extrapolate is coming in
the near
future
the ability to leverage these things
that the AI may not be misaligned but
that bad people will have a force
multiplier in AI that their ability to
con other people has gone up and the
ability to resist has not gone up at the
same rate
they already have such an ability to
calm people I'm not sure how much more
it can go up like aren't we at the point
oh don't say things like that Creon man
I think we dispelled for over the last
couple years so it's like yeah well I
think we're in for a rough ride but then
there is the simple fact that if
everybody has these things in their
Arsenal
then it's going to be very hard to know
how to evaluate anything you hear from
just about anyone
or anything you see
um these things are concerned I
understand your concern I mean do you
have a bright side
[Laughter]
can you think of a bright side because I
sure can
but again the bright side is that
um
a were not cooked yet and it's possible
we could level up faster fast enough but
B more importantly
and I'm borrowing here from my friend
alexandros marinos
but I think I heard you're uh that was a
good one I heard that say that again
your discussion with him it was great
yeah yeah he's uh he's a very
interesting guy and and his point
his point has two two sides to it one is
there are many
uh Wicked problems in the organization
of a of a society that we have not
solved and AI offers the potential for
generating Solutions we cannot access
directly which I believe is accurate
and his other point which is not quite
the Silver Lining that that first point
is is that we are already so screwed
with respect to our current trajectory
and the dysfunction that flows from it
that the danger that AI will hasten a
bad end though it is real is not
something that should preoccupy us
because what we're really looking for is
something that can steer us out of the
nose dive that we're already in all
right well that's that's uh
that's a sort of uh
what is the word there that's like
calling that an optimistic as of
stretching the bounds of optimistic well
you know when you come to me for for
optimism you're already kind of scraping
the bottom of the barrel there fair
enough I'd like to say and again I'm not
a therapist so I don't know if this is
true and I'd like to have some
therapists weigh in on this after they
do some serious work I think that
language models could be really good
therapists or at least
not necessarily really good therapists
but adequate therapists to intervene
for people who are depressed who like
can't afford a therapist I mean I think
that that they could be trained to
really coach people out of uh bad
situations I think they could actually
I mean because really if you think about
it what do they do they create
talk they create words they create
sentences and things like this and so
who does that for a living well yeah
journalists do it and you know uh well I
guess podcasters do it and um and
pundits do it you know but but there's a
whole class of people who heal people
with words and I suspect that that these
things might be really good to help
depressed people violent people even
get back on track
well I see
a
if all you did
was prevented them from having the
capacity to prescribe drugs that don't
work and make your problems worse that
that would be an improvement but
I would also say
in order to to refine the capacity that
you're talking about and mind you
realize that
an llm
that
was trained to respond to to augment
capacities that the person being talked
to
uh
felt were positive could produce very
bad effects it could reinforce you right
for example
if you take and mind you regular shrinks
can do this too but
if you and actually the economic model
around psychology is likely to do this
if somebody walks into the office of a
shrink
and
they are unhappy because the people
around them don't like them don't want
to spend time with them don't want to
collaborate with them in business
whatever
the shrink helps the person feel better
about themself that may be exactly the
opposite of what the person needs the
person no I agree it's not just about
feeling better it's about making it's
about moving your life into the
direction that you would
so in order in order for llms to do that
properly you have to train them on
metrics
that are long-term well-being metrics
rather than short-term feel better
metrics
right well I just think this is a very
interesting fertile ground ground that
I'm not going to pursue I'm not going to
make an AI therapy company but I bet
there's hundreds of people who are are
trying
so before we close this out I know there
were a couple other topics that you
wanted to discuss
uh what were they
well I mean I've got a long list and
we're not going to get through it maybe
another time but for I have I wanted to
go back to uh something revisit because
I realized I missed uh the question that
I wanted to ask you and then maybe we
can go on to vision and Carrington
events and that sort of thing if you
care to revisit that but going back
question is um you know how I was saying
that we wanted to have a NASA style
failure investigation board and I didn't
see it happening and regarding covid and
now it's maybe too late but you were
noticeably present on the DeSantis
Commission
did anything happen with that I mean I
saw that what was available on video
um uh you did great you know a lot of
you did exceptionally well as did others
but then what like did you get called
back did they get called back are they
going to do anything do you know because
that seems the closest thing that seemed
like the closest thing it is a the
public health Integrity committee I
think it's a great idea it is not the
kind of thing that is best deployed at
the level of an individual state but
what I like about what DeSantis is up to
uh and
um his Surgeon General uh ladapo they
are
using
the power of a large State the way
California
often gets environmental regulations to
to take hold because California is a
very large state it can drive people to
do things like clean up the exhaust
coming from their cars so that we have
less smog Etc so by using Florida as an
oasis of reason on topics like covid
we can model what a proper response
should look like and investigate what it
is that took place and how how it came
to be so yes I'm still on that panel uh
I don't know what happens next with it
and there is a limit to how far a single
state can go but I'm I'm very pleased
with how it has functioned so far have
there been like further meetings
there have been a couple of in-person
meetings
um and the the committee still exists
well good I hope they I hope they issue
a giant report of some sort or do
something to like
because
there as far as I know there's no and I
could be wrong about there's no body of
serious
investigators who yeah I agree uh and it
needs one I should I misspoke it's not a
couple of meanings there have been three
in-person meetings and we still exist as
a body so we'll see where it goes yeah
let's see so
um I know you have these uh I wanted to
know if if your thinking has evolved at
all on fission power and particularly
you're kind of the year that particular
kind of doomy scenario that you came up
with about um Carrington events and
spent fuel pools and um uh or fishing
power in general if your thinking has
evolved any
has changed or if you'd like to revisit
that because it's a kind of yeah it's
evolved a little bit as a result of
conversations with a number of people
who are well informed my position has
moved a little I think their position
needs to move a lot
but
um let's just say this
I would not rule out the possibility
that fission could play an important
role in the future what I'm going to be
very hard to persuade about is whether
or not the designs that are currently
deployed are rescueable or are they too
flawed to be utilized on the basis that
the spent fuel that they produce has no
mechanism by which to detoxify it no
long-term plan for storing it that is
viable and that the hazard it poses to
hired life is so significant that those
those designs should never have been
deployed in the first place
okay go ahead sorry
say again no go ahead I'm sorry I
interrupted well that said there are
other
fourth gen reactor designs that not only
could potentially have a Fail-Safe
capacity built into them that would be
satisfactory but could actually Aid in
the process of doing away with waste
we've already produced
yeah well okay I'm not going to argue
against Advanced reactors
um and um I so therefore I agree with
that last bit that you said
um
so where is all this higher life that's
been destroyed by the current uh
third generation previous reactors
um where are the species
excuse me where are the species that
have been driven extinct by
nuclear weapon exchanges
well we haven't been having nuclear
weapon exchanges for 60 years but we've
been certainly building more nuclear
power plants and running are you do you
deny that nuclear weapons have the
capacity to destroy uh species that we
could
alter the globe with nuclear weapons in
such a way that
um you know we might lose many organisms
yeah I'm not enough of a biologist to
know how many species we could if we set
our minds to it not set our minds to it
because of them ignored them and on and
off they got into an exchange with
another nuclear power uh I have a
feeling that would be most I have a
feeling humans would suffer the most
from that but except for perhaps some
rare animals in zoos in large cities
that might actually go extinct because
the last of them disappear when the
cities get nuked but I don't I mean you
tell me if I'm wrong like I don't
imagine that um
I mean
I
did Japan I believe you're I believe you
are wrong and the fact that we have not
driven anything to Extinction with
nuclear weapons does not mean that it is
outside the realm of possibility or even
probability if we were to get into a
major nuclear exchange and so I'm not
going to be arguing for major nuclear
exchanges no matter
whether the extinctions of species or
not I'm kind of are going to argue
against I mean that's obviously to be
avoided at all cost but with nuclear
power it's a different thing with
nuclear power we've been we've been you
know rather than get into this debate in
detail right now I'm going to suggest do
you want me to suggest a guest for you
uh offline or online
um I mean I've I've got guests who uh I
would be interested in having this
discussion with and I in fact I already
had one discussion
um with Michael schellenberger that I
thought was very productive
um
but uh anyway
well I urge you to have a look even if
you don't invite him as a guest have a
look at um Brett kugelmas have you heard
of him
nope great first name God wouldn't
anyway uh how many teas does he have uh
I
don't know actually one or two
um and um so uh
he has been doing a podcast on nuclear
energy
into the thousands of episodes
he's and he's interviewed and talked to
he claims 10 000 people in Industry
government
uh
uh Academia
Etc and his this is his gig is vision
and um
you should hear you should hear some of
his lectures on it because the problem
is if you if you talk to the people
who's gig is virology
you would have been
drenched in nonsense for three three
years it is for us to do gain of
function research and blah blah right
right you would have gotten a nonsense
so I'm not all that impressed with us
going to the people who have the deepest
perspective because the deepest
perspective may just be wrong well wait
a minute the deepest I mean he talks
well look I don't I'm not saying he's
wrong I don't know his work but my point
is I'm not impressed by the number of
podcast episodes were they good episodes
um I'm on board were they Bad episodes
not so much uh okay I guess my point
would only be that um
that
he's he got some very interesting
contrarian views on nuclear energy or
excuse me dissident views on nuclear
energy and
um for instance one of them is uh that
that you know who's actually responsible
for these slowdown who is most
responsible for the Slowdown and cost
escalation and
um
trouble that the nuclear industry is in
in the United States you know whether
you think it's a good idea or not like
most people if you ask them this
question like who stopped nuclear power
you know they're going to be like well
it was the environmentalist or it was uh
The Regulators and it's like no it was
the nuclear industry they just found
they could make more money selling
safety upgrades than building reactors
in the U.S and so that's what they've
been doing is selling safety upgrades
um now you know one might argue that
through safety upgrades are are
wise investment or that they're not but
the industry just pivoted and they're
like you know
we don't want to produce power we want
to produce
you know safety scanners and stuff like
this
we want to vaccinate the reactors to
make them prevent them right yeah well
anyway I think I think I think that I
suspect Brett that if you do a deep dive
on fission power uh deeper even than you
may already have that you will change
your opinion even more I suspect well
look I would love to change my opinion
if it was actually viable because energy
is a key concern producing energy in a
way that is actually
non-destructive of the biosphere is
great but it has to work that way long
term
right yes I agree it has to work that
way long term so a good thing to look at
is Fukushima Fukushima is the worst
possible accident that you could imagine
for a
water moderated reactor no way
we got lucky and we avoided the worst
accident barely barely no I don't
understand the worst accident was
multiple meltdowns total failure of all
backups the worst accident which we were
not far from was an accident that forced
the abandonment of the site
people maintained control barely
barely
that was a that was a terrible accident
but it was the tiniest fraction of what
might have happened
really yeah all right well this is
something that he
I should revisit and you should revisit
although perhaps
not with each other because I have a
feeling that maybe both of us might be a
little bit um over our skis on this one
but the truth is out there as they say
I'm not even wearing skis man okay
well
um
it it does seem to me that I mean I know
you're good it's the same same old
argument again it's like
nobody was killed from radiation at
Fukushima and you had like complete
failure of all these reactors all at
once and and oh and a tsunami on top of
it all else killing tens of thousands I
don't I don't know where you get the
idea well I do know where you get the
idea that no one was killed what I don't
understand is why you do not deploy the
same skepticism on this one given the
level of perverse incentives that you
would deploy in the context of covet
because I think the Fukushima Panic
narrative shares a lot with the covid
Panic narrative and so I am deploying
similar skepticism
I don't I don't think so
um
I think by and large I find that people
don't know what happened at Fukushima
and just unaware and
you know it had it had news cycles for a
while but people don't understand
they don't understand the difference
between
radiation and uh radionuclides that have
escaped into the environment they don't
understand
the difference between mixed oxide fuels
and regular fuels they don't understand
what the explosions that tore apart the
reactor buildings were what caused them
they don't understand the design well
people don't even understand the basic
differences between Chernobyl and
Western
no it's like if they don't get they
don't get understand that then it's like
we're not even past the first half hour
of classroom reactor design so I think
that I think it's a fascinating thing
unfortunately my Plate's kind of full
and so uh but I look forward to you
having a really qualified Festival
another really qualified guest on on
your uh podcast to to talk about this
character all right but but but but but
uh to be fair I have had one such guest
and we did discuss this very issue and
while was this a recent one about Sean
burger or an older one uh it's an older
one it's not the most recent one it was
just on but he and I uh you know it
wasn't that long ago in the last year
somewhere all right
gosh I can't believe I missed it I
thought I would listen to you
religiously but
you don't have to we have lots of
atheists in our audience too well
I uh I really enjoy it I'm gonna have to
I'm gonna have to go a couple minutes
Brett but I really want to thank you for
taking the time to talk with me it's uh
and I want to just again give you and
Heather and Zach lots of love because
you're doing holy work
appreciate that
um thank you very much for joining me
it's been a great conversation
where can people find you
well there's not that many Creon Levits
that show up when you do it I would
grant you that
yeah you can find a few of my lectures
on YouTube uh and and for and workshops
that I've participated in and I have a
little sub stack they can find me in
Palm Springs if they're ever coming
through
call
uh I think it's called creon.substack
but
oh no it's called Mutual information
Mutual information and your and I'm not
gonna call it by its new name your
Twitter handle
my Twitter handle is Creon
it's Creon there you go been there since
uh
since back long before it was in Twitter
before it was Twitter no I mean it was
like I remember when Twitter was a
novelty that only only a few computer
geeks move out and so right well it's an
idea that still doesn't make any sense
you're gonna
these very limited fortune cookie
messages and broadcast them into the
void and why would anybody do that right
well apparently it was it's worth a lot
of money yes no in retrospect it's a
great idea but uh it's it's like it's
like velcro or a zipper if you describe
it to somebody it doesn't sound all that
likely to work
I look forward to uh our past Crossing
in real life again Brett uh me as well
all right I'm at a run now thanks
everyone for joining us
[Music]